there have been drugs that have had bad
side effects when you get into the into
gene editing and saying okay should
people be able to pick characteristics
of babies you know you get very strong
negative reactions to it being used like
that we have a little bit of that in the
digital space where people look at super
intelligence on computers you know
taking over and you know so so
absolutely you know technology rarely
comes in a totally pure form I'm big fan
of Technology it's you know created the
modern lifestyle we have today but
pollution and all sorts of things
sometimes there are negative
consequences and we have to be smart
about those do you worry about the
future that future the future in which
automation augmented reality machine
learning artificial intelligence play a
greater role and what we do every day
the impact perhaps that that's going to
have on the labor force the implications
for inequality I think overwhelmingly
every one of those technologies provides
way more positive opportunity than
threat when you have some like weapons
technology you know that's purely a
negative thing the idea that somebody
would take by all biological tools and
create a weapon that is very scary and
you know I that that would be sort of
the ultimate misuse of the advanced
technology